I start tonight with big news on Capitol
Hill my sources are now telling me in no
with every detail you'd want this
week-long battle that we've had this
political battle in our nation's capital
is now almost over Kevin McCarthy is now
on the verge of becoming the next
Speaker of the House
he is now just really two boats away
from securing the gavel based on the
votes that I know and when the house
goes back into session sometime in the
next few minutes it appears that he is
on a path to get the votes take a look
for yourself Mr McCarthy do you think
you have the votes to be elected speaker
tonight yes you do yes and you'll be
able to flip Rosendale and crane I'll
have the votes what are you what were
their concerns
pretty fun let me be clear about one
thing do I wish that this week's
negotiations have been wrapped up behind
closed doors all done wrapped in a nice
bow before January 3rd before this week
yeah I kind of wish that I bet all of
you wish that as well right but uh am I
angry at the group of Republican
lawmakers from the freedom caucus that
I've always supported that fought for
assurances that we were not going to get
another John Boehner another weak leader
uh as Speaker I'm glad we're not going
to have that as well Kevin McCarthy is
not John Boehner he already signed his
name as you know we've gone over it to
the commitments to America with a long
list of America First promises and
policies we've gone through all of that
in great detail he also agreed to a one
vote threshold for a motion to vacate
and that means any one Republican can
now Force the vote sort of like a no
confidence vote to oust the speaker of
the house again if he doesn't live up to
the promises that he has made made to
his fellow colleagues and to you the
American people if he turns into John
Boehner Jr just one member can force a
vote and he can be removed from office I
don't think we're going to have that
happen I think they are all United in an
agenda that I think most conservatives
will like now McCarthy also reportedly
agreed to add Freedom caucus members to
the all-important rules committee he
agreed to hold individual votes on each
of the 12 Appropriations bills and
exclude earmarks from any bills he also
agreed to hold a vote on term limits for
members of Congress and a vote on very
specific legislation surrounding border
security security that is necessary and
a vote on a balanced budget amendment
along with a 72-hour notice before
holding a vote on any specific piece of
legislation wouldn't it be nice if they
actually read it before they voted on it
now
other assurances surrounding the debt
limit have reportedly also been secured
including caps on discretionary spending
and a ban on any bill that increases
spending without greater or equal
offsets now it's time for them to get to
work it's time to conduct oversight it's
time to hold the Biden Administration
accountable for the first time in two
years our country needs leadership
desperately now we need the
investigations to commence including
probes into the Biden family Syndicate
Don't you think it's time I think it's
time
we need to find out if our FBI has any
political bias we need to know if there
is weaponization of the law at our
department of justice malfeasance at the
CDC we need an investigation would you
all agree into Anthony fauci
I'd like to know what he knew and when
he knew it what about Alejandro mayorcas
uh our homeland security secretary he
says the border secure
we had 5 million people come in in the
last two years illegally and of course
all the Mayhem at the southern border
then we had The Botch withdrawal from
Afghanistan so much more all of that now
will be investigated the way it should
be now can Republicans fix our federal
government overnight they cannot but
they can shine a light on its failures
all the misdeeds they can hold people
accountable they can't hold their feet
to the fire and for the first time now
in two years they can finally say no to
stop Joe Biden this is the guy that
doesn't know today is Friday and his
Reckless agenda right in its tracks you
agree with me right did you
how many how many people think that Joe
Biden knows today's Friday
okay not a single person great audience
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else